[Music]
available over the counter now
contraceptive pills that have previously
required a prescription
all that's needed now is a consultation
with a pharmacist
the cost of the pills as little as seven
pounds fifty for a month's supply
this is the landmark in the history of
women's health
ever since the contraceptive pill first
came about which was over 60 years ago
so for the past 60 years
if a woman wants to get hold of a
contraceptive
medication they need to make an
appointment um to see a gp
and now it's so much more accessible
because they can literally walk into a
pharmacy without making an appointment
many believe it's long overdue when you
go talk to gps they're not
exactly the nicest about it i mean i
know it's free and people who can't go
to gps
and don't have that access will be able
to have
protection basically having the ability
to have access to that
i think is a good thing i don't think
it's going to make anyone any less
responsible than they would have been
anyway
the pills now available over the counter
are progesterone only
known as the mini pill combined pills
that contain estrogen
and have a higher risk of side effects
will still require a prescription
lauren dyer developed two blood clots in
her lungs after taking a combined pill
yeah i could have died she believes
women should have to speak to a doctor
before taking any kind of contraception
if
um you know you're looking to be under
contraceptive
that's any type of birth control it
needs to be discussed with
your gp because it should be done on a
case-by-case basis
to make sure that you know any symptoms
or side effects that you may get from
any
birth control is discussed with you
the pills now available over the counter
have been deemed
safe for most women by the uk medicines
regulator
and some say they should be available in
community pharmacies
free of charge for those who can't
afford to pay for them
it's hoped making contraception easier
to get hold of
will lead to fewer unplanned pregnancies
and give women more control over their
bodies
becky johnson sky news